no sir security is not letting women on
the lot for sexual favors yes sir thank
you thank you all i remember it's been a
little rough since Buffy ended you know
today on the gate show Jeff DeLuise
business celebrity brother Sarah
Silverman cell phone Olympic and music
by George Cal for the angriest band and
now a man who thinks America's Got
Talent except for Alaska and Hawaii fred
stoller hey have you been watching a lot
of via TV wolf you know that movie 127
hours a guy so trap he cuts his own arm
off I felt like that on some of the
dates I've been on oh I feel I'm losing
Twitter followers faster than Gilbert
Gottfried at a sushi bar you know he he
had that controversy I got agree i'd
even create more buzz and get more
followers than let him how do you
interrupting my show for I'm sorry but
what you gotta do is go viral and get it
sex tape huh what look what it did for
Kim Kardashian and Paris Hilton I gonna
be naked on tape the idiots mine Colin
Farrell did it also and no one looked at
his junk and then tom sizemore he got on
that dr. drew show huh you're crazy
sarah silverman on
there are Silverman you're a headline
again Sarah I'm gonna let you lead I'm
gonna let you run with it you can plug
your book on when your rants the funnier
ants were you mad is that your cat you
have one cat or two cabs just one yet
lonely I mean cuz don't you work all day
it's better to have to this is inside
showbiz stuff at Sarah Silverman it is
kind of the stuff we've been wanting
again I like this where is stage 33 um
Sarah all right one last question really
quick okay I know just gonna sound
strange and maybe we can help each other
out maybe you're not doing so well I see
you're driving this car we could both
use a boost and if we had a sex tape we
had a while it'll hit here Mia look we
seem to have a rapport what about Jewish
we care about cats and that's such a big
deal everyone has one today sex tape
would be like crazy buzz me and you and
Fred look at a different Paris Hilton
Kim Kardashian I think Michelle Obama
had one please open the gate I mean look
I'll do all the nudity I'll be on top
I'll cover you so all the nudity will be
on me okay maybe you show a little
nudity the lady nudity because people
like that how about wednesday no no
Wednesday stop thank you
all right let me get down and dirty yeah
we're gonna have some kinky take sex our
own private sex tape all right what do
you think what do you say there's only
sex me and Fred they're lonely expand
Fred these sex tapes help careers you
get famous and no one remembers the
nudity yeah I smell nice well old geek
know with it work everyone knows sarah
silverman doesn't have a detached head
but they'll never buy it if it's just a
head